The Reason Champagne is Broken on New Ships
While today breaking a bottle of champagne
over the hull of a ship is considered tradition
before launching a vessel in certain countries,
particularly Britain and the United States,
people have been performing ceremonies at
launches seemingly as long as humans have
made boats.
Like today, this was essentially for the hope
of good fortune on the ship’s voyages.
For instance, one of the earliest known references
to a similar practice when launching a ship
goes all the way back about 5,000 years ago
when a Babylonian stated, “To the gods I
caused oxen to be sacrificed,” before launching
a new ship he’d made.
The ancient Greeks, Romans, and Egyptians
also called upon their various gods to protect
a new ship and her crew upon its initial launch.
For example, the ancient Greeks, during their
launch festivities, would drink wine to honor
the gods and pour water on the ship as a sort
of blessing.
The religious aspects of ship christening
remained well into more modern times, particularly
in Catholic nations.
For example, there’s an account of a ship
christening by the Knights of Malta in the
seventeenth century that describes two friars
boarding a new warship, praying, and sprinkling
holy water all around the ship before deeming
her seaworthy and sending her out into the
water.
After the Protestant Reformation, kicking
off in earnest after Martin Luther’s 1517
“Ninety-Five Thesis”, certain nations
in Europe did away with some aspects of the
religious part of the christening.
Rather than use religious leaders for this
task, members of the monarchy or military
leaders would take over the christening duties.
For instance, 65 years before the above Knights
of Malta reference, in 1610, the Prince of
Wales was present at the christening of the
Prince Royal.
In this instance, there was a standing cup
on board the ship, which is just a large and
expensive cup made of some precious metal,
usually silver.
The Prince took a ceremonial sip of the wine
in the cup before throwing the rest of the
contents across the deck.
The cup was then thrown off the side of the
ship to be caught by a lucky observer.
Late in the seventeenth century, the standing
cup ceremony was replaced with breaking a
bottle of wine over the bow.
This switch was in part because the cups were
extremely valuable and the British navy was
growing rapidly; it just wasn’t practical
to continue to give the expensive cups away
every time a ship was launched.
As for the switch from wine to champagne,
it’s thought that preferences simply switched
with the times.
Champagne came to be seen as an “aristocratic”
choice -for a time in the nineteenth century
being more popular than wine among many elite
–and, therefore, considered the best option
for ship christening.
The tradition of using it has stuck around
ever since in certain countries.
Bonus Facts:
• Rather than use champagne to christen
new ships, in Japan, it’s traditional to
have a special silver axe made with the axe
being used to cut the lines holding the ship
from plunging into the water.
After the cutting ceremony, the axe is usually
kept by the ship’s owner.
• Wine and champagne haven’t been the
only types of liquid used for ship christening
throughout even recent history.
Whisky, brandy, and even sea water have been
used as well.
For instance, during Prohibition in the United
States, alcohol fell out of favour somewhat,
and water, juice, and cider were often used
in its stead.
• Today, it’s considered bad luck if the
bottle of champagne doesn’t break on the
ship.
In 2007, the Duchess of Cornwall attempted
to smash a bottle of champagne against the
hull of the Queen Victoria, but the bottle
didn’t break.
A few weeks later, nearly eighty passengers
became sick with a contagious stomach bug.
They called it “Camilla’s Curse” and
pointed the finger at the Duchess for failing
to break the bottle against the ship properly.
Obviously, it’s all superstition, but to
avoid the “bad luck,” people have come
up with a variety of ways to ensure that the
bottle breaks.
The main problem is that the bottles have
been designed not to break—you want your
champagne in the bottle, not all over the
floor, after all.
They also have to withstand high pressure
from within, so they’re pretty tough eggs
to crack.
But when a bottle has some small defect in
it, its strength becomes compromised.
Scoring the bottle beforehand with a glass
cutter is one common way to ensure the bottle
will bust on the hull of the ship.
Similarly, using bigger bottles means that
the bottle is more likely to have some natural
defect that will make it easier to break.
Choosing a type of champagne with larger bubbles
is also favourable, because it usually means
that the bottle is under a higher pressure
and more likely to break.
Ropes are often used to swing the bottle toward
the ship, and those with less elasticity are
better, because the elasticity would absorb
some of the shock needed to break the bottle
when it connects with the ship.
• It’s commonly thought that the bottle
used to christen the Titanic didn’t break,
and because of that it was doomed to sink.
This is a myth.
While it’s true no bottle was broken against
the Titanic’s hull, none of the White Star
Line ships were actually christened that way.
Obviously, not every White Star Line ship
sank because of the lack of traditional launch.
One of the men who broke the supports from
the Titanic at her launch did sustain fatal
injuries on the job, which could be taken
as a bad omen if you like to look into that
sort of thing.
The fact remains, though, that the bottle
not breaking when it hit the Titanic is a
myth because it wasn’t ever attempted.